have you ever wondered what does Islam
say about Jesus can Muslims really be
the Antichrist if they believe in get
this believe in and love Jesus I'm very
confident that if you gave some time to
hearing our view on Jesus that it would
really intrigue you and make much sense
to you now Jesus as we know is a figure
who is loved and revered by billions of
people the world over yet there is much
confusion surrounding the status of this
colossal personality Muslims and
Christians both hold Jesus in high
regard to view him in very different
ways let's first look at the idea of
Jesus as God some Christians claim that
Jesus is God or a part of a Trinity that
he is the incarnation of God on earth
and that God took on human form
however according to the Bible Jesus was
born he ate slept prayed and had limited
knowledge all attributes not befitting
God God has attributes of perfection
whereas man is the opposite how could
anything be to complete opposite
simultaneously that doesn't make sense
Islam on the other hand teaches that God
is always perfect to believe that God
became a man is to claim that God is or
was at some point in time imperfect
that's why a Christian must ask him or
herself does that idea of God who was
once a week helpless child one who could
not survive without food drink or sleep
be the same Almighty God described in
the Old Testament
surely not my friends one may ask if God
can do anything
why can't he become a man now by
definition God does not do ungodly acts
please understand this God does not do
anything that would make him something
other than God if God became man and
took on human attributes he would as a
result no longer be God now we do
understand some ambiguous verses the
Bible can be applied erroneously meaning
incorrectly forcing to fit
call it to show that Jesus is in some
way divine but if we look at the clear
distinct verses of the Bible we see
again and again that Jesus is being
referred to as an extraordinary human
being a prophet a messenger the Messiah
anointed when translated Christ and that
is exactly the Islamic view on Jesus he
was all of these but in no way shape or
form did Jesus ever claim to be God
Almighty or did he call to be worshiped
alongside with God remember this is
important
Jesus he only called people to worship
the one God full-stop you'll notice the
Bible with all due respect though it's
been changed edited tampered with by man
and this is confirmed by many Bible
scholars and his basic knowledge in
textual Bible seminary school it does
still contain many verses and which
Jesus speaks and behaves as if God has
set a separate being to himself for
example 1 Jesus fell on his face and
prayed Matthew 26:39 the question is if
Jesus was God then would God fall on his
face and pray and who would he be
praying to - the Bible calls Jesus the
Prophet Matthew 21 10 so how could Jesus
be God and be God's prophet at the same
time 3 Jesus said I'm going to the
Father because the father is greater
than me this is in John 14 28 jesus said
I ascend unto my father and your father
and to my god and your God this is in
John 20:17 and who was he ascending to
for now if Jesus was God he would
clearly he would have clearly told
people to worship Him and there would be
clear verses in the Bible stating this
yet he didn't
opposite and disapproved of anyone
worshipping him it stated that Jesus
said and in vain do they worship Me
this is in Matthew 15:9 now this was all
said with the deep love and respect for
Jesus and for our Christian friends and
all the not yet Muslims because everyone
has it in them to willingly submit to
the will of God that's what a Muslim is
and Islam means submission to the will
of God and that is exactly what Jesus
did this is Jesus the mighty messenger a
prophet of God in Islam whom we love
please don't forget to like and share
also do your best to help us reach our
goal for more info check into the
description below and in the words of
jesus Shalom said I am pleased be with
you